have you seen a dual use
air and ground vehicle maybe a swarovski
studded bathtub
well now you can go to the big boys toys
event here in las vegas starting today
okay we've got bianca holmen joining us
live with the preview boy that bathtub i
mean that's almost like a the gold
toilets that we've talked about for
celebrities
a little bit it's kind of cool though
bianca
so here take a look at this toy this is
here at the world market big boys toys
exhibition this is a beauty and this is
just one of several things that you can
see here at world market i'm joined by
bijou so thank you for joining us tell
us i know you were here in 2019 gone
last year how does it feel to be back
here in las vegas very excited
and we are this year launching a bbt
innovation summit
so it's it's getting bigger better and
more exciting products and i know this
is of course open to the public unlike
some exhibitions like this it's only
open to industry professionals but
people can come out and see these
amazing luxury items
bbtv.com and 10 only on saturday and
sunday so you can come experience the
most innovative products in the world
yeah well one thing that we're excited
to see is a flying yes a flying vehicle
you can drive it you can fly it take a
look at it right here i'm joined by
michael uh with uh um tell me the name
of your
company so tell us about this product i
mean you're telling me that people from
across the world have purchased this and
they can go on land and in the air
absolutely go anywhere and that's what
we say it's ultimate ultimate mobility
so for people who want to get up and go
around
for a lot of wildlife management
to go check on your cattle just to go
and have an adventure yeah and you're
telling me that you don't need a lot of
space to have you know a runway to get a
running start with this so tell me how
much space do you need to really get up
in the air we say 700 feet but that's
kind of worst case scenario usually
you're off the ground a lot faster than
that
and what is the most exciting thing you
know you say when you see people when
they experience this do people get to
test drive it while they're here
i don't i don't know if we're doing any
test drives here
but people just fall in love with it if
you walk around every every part of the
machine has been really carefully
crafted it's all it's designed on this
machine here designed for military use
um and then we'll sell probably about 20
of them um on the civilian market and
the rest will go for government defense
this year well it also looks good i mean
again it's a pretty loud vehicle we
heard you when you were coming on in but
pretty cool stuff and if you want to see
it live in person of course big boys
toys you can come here on the weekend
and we of course will have information
on our website bianca coleman live local
now
all right it looks like um knight rider
or airwolf or something that that dead
flying vehicle has got or a giant bug
right something like that interesting
all right get your order ready for the
swivarsky crystal bathtub though start
saving now you can buy it about 35
million years all right it's 5 40. come